-Hey guys, how's it going? So it's Jenna's birthday.
-Oh no I'm getting older!
We did this really fun video in easter where she was my arms?
-Oh no
-Don't do the juggling! My hands wont stop juggling!
It didn't go well. It didn't.
Here's something else that didn't go very well. I went to a tool concert, and I asked for a small hoodie
She gave me large. So you put your arms in there, do I go this way wait
no, other way like you look I'm putting it on yes, and then I
is this gonna even close?
Okay, wait, wait. Do I not go in the hole wait you're in your own. I'm in the hole ah
Uncomfortably close. Oh my God here. Okay? Is that good?
Well my mic is in your back okay, so maybe I'll just move this I
Don't understand. I still I know I'm here living it then I still don't understand it
Here we go look this over your butt. No way. That's gonna be my boy
Okay, okay, all right. Yeah, what can you can you fix my hair Jen? What do you want to do?
You know like part it like nice. Oh, that's nice
Okay, wait my hair. Can you okay you?
Arms doesn't mean my mobility is strengthened. Okay fix my right hair other side's like
I need like pull away from my face away from ya, okay. We're doing it close by my eye
Okay
Okay, wait one more on that side. That's nice. You just ready show me your arms. Oh those are my arms okay, so today
We're Gonna make some cupcakes
And I'm super excited because I've got a lot of really good things here for you
Three so filming could you really sleeves up what you got?
Okay, so we're gonna start with pink all right. I don't know I'll just yeah, no you don't have well
You're taller than me
Okay, okay. You want a hat
Do I have I have?
I
Gotta get a hat four legs. Oh stop it
I'm so high I'm done
Stupid time to decorate okay. Let's pick up a cupcake, okay?
I've got my cupcake right here, and now I'm gonna get some icing I prefer to get the pink icing that
looks to be the vanilla, so I'm gonna go over just a little bit no more colors, but now let know what's
That one now that I've got my pink icing this there's a lot of Sprinkles on the top, and I'm gonna be very very careful
Do you know how I get it sprinkled everywhere, so I need to get a spatula?
It's funny because I think there's one yep, oh
Boy, I've got a big one. Let me roll my sleeves up
Oh, you know?
Okay, big blob wait. I've got an Alien arm
I got my cupcake here and what I would like to do is I'm going to just
Flip my spatula over the other way, and I'm Gonna just gently slide the cupcake onto the ice
oh
That looks very good
Very very nice. Oh looks like I've got a little bit
Pink is my favorite color when I like working with icing I love using pink pink
I'm kind of hard of seeing so
Okay, now that I've got at least one cupcake ice I'm gonna start doing some decorating let's see. What else I can see
I'm just gonna pick up some sprinkles. These are my favorites
They're silver and they're very ear doesn't
This is homemade and fresh, but it's store-bought okay now that I've got my sprinkles
I'm gonna try to Sprinkle it on okay
Now I'm gonna know that's my a cupcake. That's my cupcake
It's weird cuz when I look down, I see cupcakes look, but you don't
Okay, that looks nice. Okay. I'm really thirsty can I have my drink no
I'm good. No, okay, just
I'm crying. I'm crying so much, okay next up. I'd like to
I'm honestly when I laughed like I cry like look can you see the tears on my face because I am a hot mess?
Is there a voice in my head that I'm hearing way? I'm having a hard time opening this one
All right here we go
We're gonna open this up and what I love so much about these is we've got nutritive tips and you can just shove a tip
on and then
Shut the tip on
Shove a tip on
Shove it the tip on and then you just pull it off. Shake it up. I guess and then
And then you go it. You don't want to go too far away from your cupcake because if you do I guess
Telling me this is silly. This is silly cooking with Justine in her arms, okay?
We're gonna just do a little bit of decorating on this one. This is a brand new cupcake. It's real fresh
I love making Cupcakes for Joey's birthday, okay? That's that's something that happened
So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna try that again
That's not as good as the other one, so I'm gonna just decorate this real nice cuz Gemma's favorite color is
I'm not actually sure what Joe's favorite color is but I seem to be doing a very good job on this one. Hey, Jenna
What's your favorite color?
Cuz I feel like really blue now. I've got one blue cupcake made for Jenna
I'm gonna see what else I've got over here Jenna loves Hershey bars
So I'm gonna try to find a hershey bar, and I I'm gonna try to find a Hershey bar
Okay
Okay, oh
I'm so sorry, I stepped on your little foot. God. I'm sweating. I'm comfortable and comforta name one I
hear Jenna, only ones two cupcakes decorated
Okay, we're gonna make a very special cupcake this for the last one cuz I'm crying Jenna's crotch is warm
And I'm feeling super uncomfortable so first I want to open up this hershey's bar
It's a very big bar. I
Don't real nice leaves up. I'm sweating. I'm sweating up a storm
that's Gonna taste like
Okay, wait, Alien, arm. So I'm gonna break the snap or the third, whatever and now we're gonna
What am I gonna? Do I'm not sure actually?
I'm gonna grab a cupcake is what I'm gonna do oh here. It is looking good
Gosh, I love icing coaster face. I just want to see what I'm doing. I like to really get up loose it personal
It's my with my subjects now. We're gonna put the candles in
I seem to be having them
It's almost like my hands are not communicating with my head okay. I'm gonna put that in that looks good
Wow, I can see it because it's very close to my face. Yeah, how old's Jenna turning this year one?
Now I need something to like this one
Created instead. I guess I'm gonna knock that one out in a while, okay, cool
So now I'm gonna light this can't oh jeez oh my God no
hairspray
Down like that
Oh my God happy birthday
Get out of here. I can't
I
Can't touch you because I thought things on my hand
Hello, okay. Thank you guys believe that wasn't one person in there. We really sold it
Happy birthday, Jenna. I'm getting too old for this
You see oh, God. I've got so much crap in my hair
What do I do now?
I'm sweating actually disgusting slut